anna et michel cartier paysans en
retraite habite toujours orchamps vennes
plus leur ferme
mais cette maison contemporaine ou
quitte sa maison quitte ses souvenirs et
c'est pas facile
une fois que la porte est fermée c'est
fermé on part
voilà on sait qu'on peut revenir non en
tant qu'invité vécu mes plus chez nous
il y a quatre ans les quartiers ont pris
leur retraite ils ont donné les clés de
leur maison et de leur exploitation à
michael je suis certain que ça marche
parce que avec michael d'adp sud est
très claire donne ses résultats
immobilier non il n'y a absolument pas
obligés il ya une confiance mutuelle
enfin et
je suis fier de ses résultats de montrer
qui a réussi à deux kilomètres de la
maison de michel la ferme aujourd'hui
confié aux bons soins de michael cédants
et repreneurs se sont mis tout de suite
d'accord sur un point le prix de
l'exploitation de 45 hectares et de 30
vaches qui produisent du lait à comté
bio mais tomber sur eux sur des cédants
qu'avec la volonté de remettre la ferme
on a eu toutes les clés pour le faire
dans des meilleures conditions possibles
en janvier dernier michael a été rejoint
sur l'exploitation par son épouse
l'organe qu'il se félicite de cette
reprise
c'est une belle histoire c'est une belle
histoire et j'espère que beaucoup
beaucoup comme nous vivrons ce cette
concrétisation d'un rêve voilà d'être
paysan l'association terre de liens veut
aider les jeunes agriculteurs à
s'installer mais pas à n'importe quel
prix en leur assurant de bonnes
conditions de travail et surtout une
excellente qualité de vie